es considerado uno de los primeros casos
en todo el mundo sobre los crímenes de
guerra contra la minoría yazid y
jennifer wayne es una mujer alemana de
30 años fue condenada por un tribunal de
múnich a 10 años de cárcel por crímenes
contra la humanidad juanes era una
integrante del grupo estado islámico y
se encargaba de patrullar las ciudades
de faluyá y mosúl antiguos bastiones de
los radicales fue durante el verano de
2015 que con su entonces esposo
compraron a una niña yazidí de 5 años a
quien ataron al exterior de su casa como
castigo por haberse orinado en su cama
la pequeña murió de sed
es decisivo que un crimen sobre el cual
nadie hubiera pensado que jamás se
resolviera haya concluido hoy en un
juicio criminal aunque criatura la madre
de la menor también fue comprada por la
misma pareja ella ahora vive bajo una
identidad secreta en el país germano y
fue quien llevó el caso ante la justicia
para ella era importante y así lo hizo
saber en el juicio que el mundo supiera
quién fue la responsable los yazidíes
son una minoría religiosa que
históricamente ha ocupado el norte de
irak
estado islámico los considera unos
infieles y se estima que han matado a
más de 3.000 de ellos esclavizado a
siete mil de sus mujeres y niñas y han
forzado el desplazamiento de la mayoría
de sus 550 mil integrantes